this is sky news breakfast and these are
our top stories
cutting the quarantine self-isolation
for fully vaccinated people with
coronavirus is reduced from 10 days to a
week we want to reduce the disruption to
people's everyday lives caused by the
pandemic
safeguarding the future have a vaccine's
blueprints could allow new jabs to be
developed within a hundred days of a new
virus being detected
[Music]
seventy million years on scientists
discover a perfectly preserved dinosaur
embryo that was preparing to hatch from
its egg
and i'm in winterfell for a world first
as sky news gains exclusive access to
the new game of thrones studio tour in
northern ireland
the weather turning more unsettled from
today bringing a risk of colder
temperatures as we head towards
christmas
and at a quarter two we'll take another
look at the papers with the presenter
and writer matthew stadlin and the
journalist and broadcaster ramona alley
[Music]
morning all the self-isolation period
for fully vaccinated people who have
coronavirus has been cut from ten to
seven days with immediate effect the
move follows confirmation from boris
johnson that no further covered
restrictions will be brought in before
christmas he says the situation remains
finally balanced with the government
waiting on figures of the number of
people going to hospital with the new
variant but many are expecting new
restrictions before the new year here's
laura bunduck
no covid curbs before christmas but the
rules are changing for self-isolation
the 10-day period now down to seven days
we want to reduce the disruption to
people's everyday lives caused by the
pandemic
so today we will be cutting the
self-isolation period from ten days to
seven days for those people that take a
lateral flow test on day six and day
seven and the result of both those tests
are negative it comes as christmas is
given the go ahead but what happens next
is much less certain we continue to
monitor omnicron very closely and if the
situation deteriorates we will be ready
to take
action if needed what this means is that
people can go ahead with their christmas
plans
but the situation remains
finally balanced and i would urge
everyone
to exercise caution meanwhile in
scotland bigger decisions have been
taken edinburgh's hogmanay won't happen
with large new year events cancelled
limits too on sporting fixtures
the uncertainty in england is hitting
hospitality hard at this point we are
normally sold out for new year's eve um
we normally sell out early on in the
christmas period so early december
we've sold about a thousand tickets
compared to the 2000 tickets that we
usually sell so we've got
about 50 000 pounds worth of ticket
revenue um
you know that we've accumulated but
we're looking potentially being faced
with having to refund all of that money
the rapid rise of omicron makes it
impossible to rule out further measures
cases of coronavirus remain high above
90 000 cases a day the biggest concern
is around the rapid spread of omicron
this chart shows how much it's gone up
in just the last six days up by a third
to over sixty thousand cases and
hospitalizations
have increased slightly but remain well
below the numbers we were seeing during
the previous surges in infections
the rate of hospital admissions will be
critical in the coming days also
important vaccination and news now the
oxford astrazeneca team is tweaking its
jab for omicron
but as we head towards christmas
celebrations feel muted families finally
together but well aware it could all
change very soon laura bundock sky news
although there are well over 60 000
confirmed cases of the omicron covia
variant in the uk more than 15 000 of
those in fact registered in the latest
24 hour periods
overall another 90
629 covered cases have been recorded
along with 172 more deaths and that
brings the total number of deaths to 147
hundred and thirty-three
as for vaccines almost forty thousand
first doses have been delivered more
than fifty thousand second doses uh that
means the total number of second doses
no more than forty seven million at one
of boosters third doses well almost 900
000 of those were delivered in the last
24 hours which brings the total to
almost 30 million
joining us once again on the program the
health minister jillian keegan ms keegan
always great to see you do hope you're
well just apologies we can't be in the
same studio during this this festive
week um
let's start with with a personal
admission from all of us it's not
feeling very very christmasy uh this
week is it but the prime minister has
said that we will still be allowed to go
with our christmas parties or on what
basis has he come to that decision
well on the on the basis that you know
we're taking sort of balanced and
proportionate um
approach to it and you know people can
still go ahead and have their christmas
i would disagree actually i had a family
meal yesterday um and it did feel very
christmasy particularly my sister made
it over from the states so uh yeah it's
feeling christmassy families are getting
together sometime for the first time in
nearly three years
i don't know maybe i'm just playing into
the stereotype of the scottish
conversion this morning but but let's
let's talk about the data
let's talk about the data though do we
on do we know do we have a figure for
how many people are in hospital at the
moment with omicron
yeah there's a 129 people in hospital
with omicron right now
the reason i ask and i'm sure you will
be aware of this on the daily brief the
daily update the omicron update it did
suggest that there were some issues
around i.t reporting those those issues
have now been dealt with
well look we're getting data from all
across the country from every hospital
which is being fed up on a daily and
sometimes hourly basis so you know
there's obviously some lags in certain
certain bits of the data but that's the
data that we're collecting 129 people as
of yesterday and 14 deaths with omicron
just in terms of of what is happening do
you feel like we are approaching the
peak of omicron or perhaps have even
peaked but paul hunter from the
university of east anglia suggesting
that numbers may have plateaued we would
have been expecting perhaps if we go on
the growth rate from two weeks ago
perhaps 200 000 cases a day instead
we're reporting around about 90 000.
no we haven't been given that
information we're watching the data very
very carefully i mean you had three
meetings yesterday where we're all
discussing the data and and taking in
those inputs so we don't know that yet
um but we are looking at the wave and
we're looking at all the data and uh
we'll we'll tell you when we think we've
passed peak
so we we haven't yet seen a major rise
in hospitalizations that we generalise
across the country but there is there is
an expectation that one is coming though
isn't it
well you know the things that are
unknown which i think we've said a
number of times that they're still
working on is the severity of the
disease and also the impact of the
vaccination and now more importantly the
vaccination plus the booster we know the
booster gives um a huge uh increase in
defense which is why we're urging
everybody and thank you so much to the
nearly 30 million people who've come
forward but for everybody else if you
haven't had your first dose it really is
never too late come forward start to get
yourself and others around you protected
just in terms of the of the negotiations
that well and it feels like their
negotiations going on around the cabinet
table your boss sanji javid none other
than the health secretary
understood to have been in favor of
bringing in restrictions earlier he told
his colleagues that doing nothing is an
as an active decision but he was he was
outvoted do you think he was correct to
be out voted around that table
look you know in the around the cabinet
table obviously you've got to get
everybody with the different views
looking from a different perspective one
will look from health one will look from
the economy one will look from transport
etc and so that's why you have a cabinet
government so you can get all of that
diversity of views and then take a
balanced approach to risk and it is a
difficult decision we do not have all
the information that you would like to
have at your fingertips in particular
as you were talking about earlier the
severity of the disease so it is a
difficult balance but we think we've got
the balance right you know saying to the
country we wanted to lock down et cetera
when you've got those kind of figures
would wouldn't look proportionate so
we're trying to be balanced we're trying
to be proportionate but most importantly
we are monitoring the data um on a on a
daily basis a couple of times a day
actually we get new inputs of data and
that's what we'll continue to do we'll
be working all over christmas and we'll
continue to do that so was the first
minister of scotland wrong to go to go
further than the prime minister then
does she know something that he doesn't
i thought they were working from the
same data set
they are and they have been all the way
through the pandemic but obviously the
devolved administrations have taken
different approaches at times and you
know that's their that's their um you
know their authority to be able to do
that um
you know people look at the data
the data is no different but i guess uh
the way they analyze the risk could be
different or they look at their
population you know we we've taken a
look at it and we've basically said you
know the hospitalizations the deaths
where we are right now as you said uh
the rising cases whilst the case numbers
are very high um you know they haven't
yet reached what was estimated only a
week ago sure but but just in terms of
further restrictions
it is fair isn't it to say that is a
question of when and not it
well obviously we've said we have to
keep that option open because you know
we are looking at cases that are going
up at the moment and we are looking at
uh hospitalization which is going up i
was on the program last week and it was
10 then now it's 129. so obviously we do
have to
reserve that option and we won't
hesitate we've said that we will not
hesitate if it's required to keep people
safe but right now the balanced and
proportionate response is we believe the
one that we've put in place
a big announcement in terms of of
isolation for those that are fully
vaccinated at the very least their
self-isolation periods be cut from 10
days to 7.
what is the science behind that why are
we now confident that people can be out
you know mixing in the community again
at day 7 rather than day 10.
well what we've done is looked at
whether serial testing on day six and
day seven uh how that uh the risk of
that uh versus wait until day ten and
effectively they've said it's equivalent
risk if you have day six and day seven
negative tests is equivalent risk to
having another three days in your
bedroom or whatever but you are asking
people who do leave their homes on
on day seven having had those two
lateral flow tests you are asking them
to minimise social contact you're asking
them to to to avoid mixing if at all
possible why is that necessary if it's
safe for them to leave the house on day
seven
we're saying that for everybody we're
saying to everybody look be cautious if
you're going somewhere i mean we we had
a family meal yesterday everyone took a
lateral flow test before make sure you
go to somewhere that's well ventilated
be cautious we're saying that to
everybody you know there's a lot of
unknowns here we still you know don't
have uh all the data that we want um so
be cautious be cautious to enjoy your
christmas
as much as anything else is this perhaps
a means by which we can help out the the
really significant staffing pressures
that there are in the health service at
the moment in the bma estimating between
32 and 130 000 it could be off work by
christmas
yeah i mean that's part of it keeping
the economy going keeping the supply
chains going keeping the nhs going and
keeping yourself going you know
everybody who's uh involved in in
in jobs uh right now for sure that is
part of of looking at whether uh people
can uh with the with the equivalent risk
can uh get back to work earlier so yes
that is part of the equation a big
package and i inspired the chancellor
yesterday a billion pounds to go to the
hospitality sector six thousand pounds
for every individual business it isn't
that a little bit like trying to fight
third world famine with a packet of
frozen peas i mean i spoke to one venue
owner yesterday who said their daily
takings at this time of year are close
to six thousand pounds
yeah sure i mean look what we're not
doing is looking to try and you know
you know
compensate all of that what we're
looking to do is to provide a a security
blanket for businesses like we did all
the way through the pandemic i mean
we've spent 407 billion pounds on on on
businesses and business supports so you
know we're just trying to do that for
this period of time we know it's really
unfortunate obviously hitting just
before christmas it is really
unfortunate so to provide that lifeline
and hopefully once we can all get back
out the great british public will do
what they do and they'll support uh all
of these businesses and get back to the
theaters and get back to restaurants
sure but
you described it as a security blanket
if it is such it is pretty threadbare i
mean tim romney chief executive of best
western he says it's just so
disappointing and underwhelming in every
sense it doesn't go far enough opinion
it doesn't go deep enough and it's too
little too late i mean why have we not
reintroduced furlough
well because people are still working i
mean i i went out for a family meal
yesterday you know there was the pub was
not every table was full but most of it
was you know people are still going out
and people are still enjoying themselves
so you know we're trying to get that
balance again but actually most
businesses i've spoken to are actually
very appreciative of this support so
obviously you found one there doesn't
think it's enough you'll always find
that but you know this is this is a
billion pounds that we have just
announced and it is there to support
businesses across our country hopefully
for a short period of time
until we can um you know get over this
latest uh variant and the wave of
disruption that it's caused
but just in terms of wages because that
clearly has been something that many in
the in the industry have been calling
out for assistance the movement
statutory sick pay helps the funds but
it doesn't help the one in six
hospitality workers perhaps as many as
240 000 people who don't qualify for it
well i mean it's there again for those
smaller firms to make sure that people
can self-isolate for up to two weeks the
government will pay um and you know it's
it's it's been very welcomed i think
from from most of the businesses that uh
i've spoken to him from what i've heard
as well you know this is something again
we're dealing with uncertainty we've
responded really quickly to this latest
uncertainty we hope it doesn't last too
long but that is uh as you know a
billion pounds that's been announced and
it is not something that should be
dismissed it's something that i think
largely is welcomed
uh minister let's let's return to the
top of our interview
where i you know self-describe myself as
a bit of a grumpy scot perhaps you can
lift my mood i mean in your mind
on the basis of the the limits that
people are already putting on their own
activity as you mentioned you know
you're in a restaurant yesterday and not
all the tables were used in your mind if
we carry on on this path and people keep
doing what they are doing is there any
chance any chance whatsoever that we
might not see that circuit breaker
lockdown that frankly everyone is
predicting
again you know we as i've said we're
waiting for data on the severity we'll
still have to wait to see um you know
where we land on that but um
we can't really say you know we've said
is up to christmas we're fine looking at
the data looking at the the numbers we
have at the moment but of course we have
to look at where this virus
goes where this variant goes so we have
to look at that data i can't tell you in
advance of getting that data but you
should be cheerful because we're doing a
lot more than we could last year we're
able to see our family as i said i have
my sister and her family over from the
states we haven't seen them for nearly
three years so lots of people are
getting to see family members that they
haven't seen for a long time and lots of
us will get together with our loved ones
at christmas
julian keegan lovely to have you on the
programme and you make sure you have a
lovely christmas when it comes
you too happy christmas and cheer up
never never
no israel it is to roll out a fourth jab
of the kovac 19 vaccine a government
advisory panel says that those over 60
and healthcare workers should get the
job first but it could eventually
include other groups israel was of
course one of the first countries to
vaccinate and carried out the first
booster campaign last summer
researchers have published a blueprint
for making millions of new vaccines
within a hundred days of a new virus
being identified that's a quarter of the
time of the current covered jabs our
reporter katie barnfield is in the
newsroom at morning again katie walk us
through this it feels like an
announcement of significance
potentially it could be yes so these
researchers say they've identified what
they say are fairly simple changes to
the manufacturing process of certain
vaccines that could make it much more
efficient and therefore produce new
vaccines much more quickly now the team
is from oxford university and this
research relates particularly to a type
of vaccine called an adenoviral vector
vaccine which includes their own
oxford astrazeneca coronavirus jab and
they say the thing that takes time when
you're producing these particular type
of vaccines is making a new seed virus
so the way that they work is by using
inactivated or weakened
forms of other viruses in order to
produce an immune response and they say
they've looked closely at how that
particular part of the process can be
done more quickly and with these
improvements it could enable clinical
trials within 60 days of the
identification of a new virus and
possibly millions of doses as you say to
be made within a hundred days and even
up to a
billion doses being made within 130 days
now this particular team at oxford
university are now looking at how they
might be able to tweak their own oxford
astrazeneca jab to respond particularly
to the omicron coronavirus variant now
we know that the oxidastogenic jab
currently
has a lot less effectiveness against
omicron than other types of vaccines
like the mrna vaccines including pfizer
and modern but now the team are saying
well now we know actually that we can
change our viruses and modify them
more quickly than possibly previously
sort of previously thought so they say
in conjunction with astrazeneca they've
started the preliminary process to
modify these vaccines and then depending
on the data seeing whether it's needed
they might be able to start producing it
fairly quickly
casey thanks very much indeed
other news and russian president
vladimir putin has blamed the west for
escalating tensions in europe russia has
amassed tens of thousands of troops on
the border with ukraine amidst fears it
plans to invade the east of the country
mr putin threatened a military response
to any aggressive course of action by
the west
and demanded that nato refuse to accept
the former soviet state as a member
the build-up of the united states and
nato's forces next to the russian
borders is of great concern as well as
large-scale military drills including
those unscheduled
we're extremely worried about deploying
the united states global missile defense
system near russia
a madagascan government minister said he
swam to safety for 12 hours after his
helicopter crashed at sea during a
rescue mission the helicopter came down
during a search for survivors of a cargo
ship that sank with the loss of 39 lives
on monday
the minister used one of the helicopter
seats
as a float to swim to shore
i am alive
i arrive safely in my hambo and i'm
grateful to all the fishers and
villagers of mohammed
also to the hotel manager mr jason
i have been swimming from yesterday at 7
30 pm to today at 7 30 a.m it wasn't my
time to die thank god
scientists have discovered a perfectly
preserved dinosaur embryo in southern
china dating back just a little less
than 70 million years a dinosaur was
preparing to hatch from its egg like a
bird speaking to me earlier fiona
ma a paleontologist at the university of
birmingham who helped research the
discovery said the fossil is one of the
best dinosaur embryos ever found
this dinosaur embryo fossil is one of
the best preserved dinosaur embryos ever
found in history so because it is so
well preserved we can look at how this
little dinosaur lies inside and uh
is ache um and so we can compare its
posture with the other dinosaurs as well
as um their descendants the modern verse
so if we look at its posture we can see
it is very similar to a close to
hatching modern day birds
festive food is of course a big part of
christmas celebrations and this year the
royal family have revealed their recipe
for the perfect gingerbread house well
not their recipe the buckingham palace
chef's recipe they've put together a
step-by-step guide on how to bake and
decorate the gingerbread from scratch
making it look just a little easier than
it might eventually prove to be when you
try it at home
time for the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the weather will turn more unsettled
from today bringing a risk of some
winter-ness as we head towards the
christmas period much of britain will
start the day frosty and clear but a few
freezing fog patches are possible
elsewhere milder with patchy rain across
ireland especially in the blustery south
that rain will extend north and east
during the morning reaching northern
ireland and western fringes of britain
most other places will stay dry with
cloud increasing but east anglia and the
southeast should hold on to some
brightness
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now the self-isolation period for fully
vaccinated people who have coronavirus
has been cut to a week just so long as
they test negative on days six and seven
meanwhile boris johnson has reassured
the public that christmas will be able
to go ahead but without further
restrictions uh joining us now professor
mike tilde a member of the sage subgroup
on scientific pandemic influenza group
or modelling good to see you this
morning professor um
let's start with that which we heard
from the prime minister yesterday and i
imagine for for a lot of people who've
been building up to december the 25th in
their minds the fact that we will not
see any restrictions this side of
christmas will please them but from a
scientific point of view from a modeling
point of view
is this the correct thing to be doing
right now
well it's it's a really difficult time
of year of course i mean we always say
you know as a modeler you always say if
you're going to introduce restrictions
then of course the sooner you introduce
it the more effective any of those
restrictions are going to be but of
course at this time of year it's really
challenging because you know given what
happened last year the very late
introduction of restrictions a few days
before christmas i think that was quite
damaging for people's mental health and
well-being so i suspect there's one eye
on that one eye on allowing families to
be together but of course we do need to
remember the omicron variant has not yet
gone away and there still is a risk
attached to um being in close proximity
particularly to vulnerable people so i
think we need to be very mindful of that
in the run-up to christmas
yeah certainly it does feel and it's
obviously just anecdotal experience of
my own you know you wander around to
high streets you go through your past
pubs and restaurants it certainly does
feel that people in advance of any
further restrictions are are limiting
their own amount of their own social
contact and certainly plenty of people
that i know will be testing themselves
regularly over the days to come leading
up to christmas but again there feels
almost an inevitability that there are
some further restrictions coming on on
the other side of boxing day or would
you disagree
i i find it very difficult to predict at
any point where when and if the
government are going to react but of
course if we are looking at cases they
are rising um we do need to of course
take that um in with the mind that
actually the number of tests that are
being carried out has also risen quite
significantly over the last week but of
course from what we are seeing in the
data omicron is spreading rapidly we're
not yet seeing that filtering into an
increase in hospital emissions in a
significant way other than in london of
course london is a little bit ahead as
it has been
at various points throughout the
pandemic and there's a big concern in
terms of the rising hospital emissions
in london and also the relatively low
vaccine coverage in london compared with
other parts of the country so that is a
concern the evidence that is coming out
though is still suggesting that vaccines
are very very effective particularly
after a booster shot so really important
that we get as many people as possible
continuing to get their boosters but but
just in terms of of the data isn't it
the case that you know for the for the
size of a data set that you would need
to provide some reliable information on
case hospitalization rate for for
omicron itself we might be waiting until
the new year
well the problem is of course there's
always a lag and we talk about this
throughout the pandemic there's always a
lag in the data so when we see cases
these individuals were infected a few
days ago but obviously when we see cases
it can take a week or two before we
start to see a rising cases reflected in
a rise in hospital emissions and then of
course when people sadly die from the
disease that happens a few days later so
any increase in cases um it's a delay
before we see an increase in hospital
emissions we're not so we're not there
yet in the data to really be able to say
confidently
the relative severity of omicron over
over delta there's some anecdotal
evidence that suggested that it's less
severe than delta but we're not there
yet been able to say that definitively
so really being able to accurately say
what the risk associated with omicron is
uh professor i'm going to be slightly
cheeky here and and ask if you do not
mind um what what you're planning to do
for christmas this year have you had to
alter your plans amend your plans cancel
plans
well i'm not yet having cancelled plans
but i'm really hoping i mean i've been a
little bit careful in terms of not
really going out kind of mixing in the
way i was before because my hope is that
over the next few days i may be able to
see my more elderly loved ones i mean to
me christmas is about my children and i
think it's really important that they
have an opportunity to be
around their loved ones over the next
few days so fingers crossed we'll be
able to do that but of course you know
there's one eye on the data and i'm also
making sure that i'm testing myself
regularly so if i am going to see my
more elderly loved ones i'm not putting
them at risk
well you know what i will keep my
fingers and toes crossed for you
professor mike totally good to see you
again and have a very merry christmas
when it comes to fingers crossed thank
you very much you too
welcome back the number of people in
hospital with the omicron variant has
risen to 120 129 now that's more than 12
times what it was just a week ago the
government says it still doesn't have
the information it needs to decide
whether further restrictions are likely
after christmas speaking to me just a
few minutes ago the health minister
jillian keegan says the government takes
into account a range of views when
settling on an approach
around the cabinet table obviously
you've got to get everybody with the
different views looking from a different
perspective one will look from health
one will look from the economy one will
look from transport et cetera and so
that's why you have a cabinet government
so you can get all of that diversity of
views and then take a balanced approach
to risk and it is a difficult decision
we do not have all the information that
you would like to have at your
fingertips in particular
as you were talking about earlier the
severity of the disease so it is a
difficult balance but we think we've got
the balance right you know saying to the
country we wanted to lock down et cetera
when you've got those kind of figures
would wouldn't look proportionate so
we're trying to be balanced we're trying
to be proportionate but most importantly
we are monitoring the data
so shorter isolation no more curbs at
christmas but there are fears that there
is some bad news just around the corner
our political correspondent tomorrow
cohen joins us from westminster good to
see you again tc what did we learn um
from the minister this morning i mean i
i think i think i counted about seven or
eight times they are keeping the data
under close review that's right and she
thinks that the data does not currently
justify a lockdown what the cabinet and
what ministers have seen so far does not
justify taking that step which of course
would mean a big hit to the economy
she's saying it's not cabinet ministers
or tory mps standing in the way of boris
johnson bringing in restrictions even
though they have been brought in on the
basis of the same data in scotland and
wales already she's saying that we need
to wait to have something firmer
although she didn't say what in
particular they were looking for with
some suggestions that the uk health
security agency might be producing more
data later this week what they're
watching very carefully is
hospitalizations and she said that the
number of hospitalizations from omicron
that have been confirmed is now 129
12 times higher than last week now we
must remember that there is a lag in
hospitals reporting
whether these are omicron cases and in
the sage documents released over the
weekend they said that there may be ten
times as many as have been publicly
reported so there's a lot of uncertainty
about the hospitalization numbers and
great concern that they have already
doubled in london over the last couple
of weeks london being the epicenter of
the cases at the moment but they are
watching it very carefully there's a
sense of when not if in terms of more
restrictions after christmas but she
told you to cheer up about christmas
because it will be a lot better than
last year
yeah i'd remember that tomorrow thank
you
i will as new restrictions are brought
in to suppress the spread of omicron
care homes which support the most
vulnerable in society are concerned over
limited government guidance uh joining
us now in the programme the chief
executive of the national care forum vic
rainer vic great to see you this morning
um can we just start with with what the
government has or hasn't
advised the care home sector to do what
what is the current advice um from
whitehall as to how you should be
proceeding as we edge into christmas
yeah so um
you're right we're waiting for large
tranches of government guidance to be
updated and you'll remember that uh
perhaps about nearly two weeks ago there
was a press release which talked about
changes that were going to happen happen
and have an impact on the care sector
particularly in relation to testing of
staff changes to the testing regime
changes to the visiting uh guidance
and a range of other things that we're
going to come in in relation to
admissions uh and
and other sides of things so far we've
had the guidance around visiting
but that is the only uh change formal
change that has been announced other
things have been kind of announced via
press release so
testing is a really good example so
in the in the press release it was
announced that there would be a change
in routine testing from two to three lfd
tests per week for all care staff
now that's a really significant change
at the drop of a hat you've suddenly
introduced 1.6 million more tests into
the system many of whom need to get
tests uh lfd tests if they're
domiciliary care workers from either the
home testing
order line or from their local community
pharmacy well i don't know if you've
been out recently to try and get an lfd
test but you can't get the level of
money either from the order line or from
pharmacies so you're asking as a huge
workforce
to change the way that they work and not
providing the prioritization
for access to those tests that they need
and not indeed updating the formal
guidance so you're getting people to
work via press release it doesn't feel
like a very effective mechanism um
for for such an important part of the
regime
yeah and on top of that of course as we
all as we know as soon as you increase
testing you increase the number of
people who will test positive which is
of course very key if you're working in
the care sector you want to go you want
to guard against people catching
the residents catching but at the same
time it is going to put even more stress
on an already overstretched care home
workforce which could potentially one
imagines lead to people perhaps not
being able to see their relatives over
christmas
i mean i think the really important
thing is you're right this is putting
pressure on on a workforce that is
already uh
under extreme pressure i mean i was
particularly
uh noted yesterday that you know the the
um
hospitality sector very rightly was
outlining the pressures that omicron
restrictions were put on it and within a
week of them doing that a billion pounds
was found for grants the social care
sector has been outlining the enormous
workforce shortages that is has been
experiencing since the summer since july
of this year there's been a massive uh
problem around recruitment and retention
and yet it took four months for the
government to come up with 162 million
pounds now that's an important amount of
money but that amounts to essentially
about a hundred pounds per worker for a
month period is not enough
there's not enough priority on the
impact of
all of these changes and indeed the
rapidly increasing impact of the virus
on the workforce absolutely sure
i mean absent some very clear advice
coming from government in the in the
immediate future there will be any
number of care home providers up and
down the country looking at what to do
over the next few days from your
perspective
would you wish to see care home
operators
taking the initiative themselves acting
in their own minds to protect their
residents but but limiting or indeed
cancelling
people being able to see their relatives
inside care homes over the christmas
period
so i you know i i and the organization i
represent national care forum has spent
months and months in fact over the last
year and a half fighting very hard for
access for visitors and i think we have
got to a really important place around
having essential caregivers who can be
part of the same testing regime
as staff
and are now part of the essential
well-being of people i would be
encouraging uh care homes across the
country to continue to have that access
for those essential caregivers is an
important part it's a vitally important
part of people's um
well-being and i think that
we need to be finding ways in which we
can continue to support that and
continue if staffing is the challenge
then we need to find ways to continue to
to boost those staffing levels so those
essential visits can continue to take
place
vic rainer from the national care forum
always good to see you you have a lovely
christmas when it comes yeah thanks and
to go to school we would make a big
difference to the air pollution around
our school yeah like us
most places will have a dry and frosty
start but island will be milder with
some patchy rain
that rain will spread into northern
ireland and western fringes of britain
during the morning most other places
will stay dry despite cloud increasing
it'll be breezy and cold for most milder
in the southwest
the afternoon we'll see patchy rains
spreading across more of britain with
snow for the scottish highlands
looking at the uk's air pollution levels
will remain low with values of two or
three on the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
joining us once again to take us through
their selection of the papers the writer
and presenter matthew stavan and the
journalist and broadcaster ramona ali
good to see you again guys um we're a
bit pushed for time so matthew let's
let's dump on in with a fantastic uh
traditional sun front page carrying a
fantastic traditional picture of the
prime minister well not quite the prime
minister looks a little bit more like
matt lucas
yeah have a good christmas but uh don't
have a good christmas and i'm sure lots
of people watching this morning will
remember much earlier in the pandemic
during i think the first lockdown when
the comedian matt lucas made that video
go viral in which she said
go to work
don't go to work go outside
don't go outside and this is a nod to
that video by the sun suggesting ongoing
confusion as to what what sort of
festive period we can all expect over
the coming days now we know that there
are going to be no further restrictions
in england ahead of christmas that gives
some certainty but at the same time as
saying our plans can go ahead the prime
minister is warning us to be careful to
keep an eye out for our loved ones
particularly those who are vulnerable to
keep the rooms ventilated and so forth
and the southern front page also making
the point that there may be further
restrictions ahead after christmas so
while christmas can go ahead new year
might not in the sort of way that we
normally expect so a lot of uncertainty
still and this is feeding through to
businesses they crave certainty because
they want to know what sort of orders
that they can put through in order to
give us the sort of new year that we
hope
uh roman it it does feel you may
disagree but it certainly feels to me
like people are
heeding the prime minister's advice that
people are trying to limit their
contacts and the reason is of course is
that no one wants to catch covered and
have to self-isolate over christmas
however as the your story in the
independent points out at least they'll
only be isolating for seven days now
yes that's right it's breaking just
today that self isolation is going to be
reduced from 10 days to seven days
following negative uh lateral flow
tester um results so the uk health
security agency
is saying that anyone infected can take
two lateral flows um 24 hours um apart
on day six and seven and if they're
negative they just stop quarantining and
and as sod's law would have it i've just
emerged from a 10-day isolation period
myself it was very uneventful there's
lots of tissues and netflix and boredom
um you know but this is really great
news as it's minimizing the disruption
to people's lives and and you know
people there are tens of thousands of
people have infected with this new
variant so many of my own uh family
members and friends are so this is
really important uh in kind of giving us
a big chunk of our our daily lives back
i was wondering which of the two of you
was going to be the grinch this morning
and i know looking at the paper listed
it's going to be you matthew page nine
of the mail junk food should get
cigarette style health warnings what
nurse is all about
may just add a quick caveat because it
is so important in a pandemic i think
there's a caveat to what ramona said
which is if you are not vaccinated you
still have to isolate for the full one
day so this applies this new guidance
applies to those who are vaccinated i'm
not sure that's actually the case
matthew let me just read you something
that my political correspondent tamara
cohen sent me she says that she's told
by the department of health that the
press release that stated the
unvaccinated would still have to do ten
days is incorrect it is seven days
regardless of vaccination status but
still 10 days for unvaccinated contacts
of positive cases so that's where
there's the the perhaps the confusion is
crept in
that's very interesting so in other
words the papers have to catch up on
that yes so to go to your story on on
the mail this is a a report in the bmj
global health and this is researchers
saying essentially that the
junk food so highly processed ultra
processed
food is the new tobacco and that we
should have tobacco type warnings on our
junk food so maybe if you buy a a packet
of cookies one day you'll see the sort
of damage that that might eventually
contribute to causing inside you much in
the same way that on a packet of
cigarettes you'll see diseased cancerous
lungs a lot of people will support that
others will say that that's going far
too far towards a nanny state really
interesting to see how that develops
because of course we have a massive
problem with obesity in in the country
at the moment and we've got a voluntary
traffic light system so it's only
voluntary but soon we will get those
pre-9 pm
non-advertising of junk food and that's
a big drive that this government has
been part of and that boris johnson has
personally championed and now i really
want a burger um ramona take us to the
front of the daily star i think it's
probably the front page of the day for
me dear santa well what does this
christmas card ask for
well it's like a luxury box of lateral
flow tests it's like the gift that
everyone needs but not not necessarily
you know like really been hoping for and
the front page here is is commenting
really on the impact that this is having
on children you know who are growing up
you know in this covid world uh you know
five year olds knowing words like you
know social distancing and and isolation
periods so this story really nods to
childhood kind of being robbed and the
memories of christmas without family is
kind of like going to be haunting them
unfortunately but you know they're
growing up with this uncertainty and
parents can't even reassure them but
children are also very you know amazing
they can adapt to environments and
they're kind of getting used to this
kind of
uncertainty unfortunately yeah that i
think is something we will reflect on in
many years to come um matthew perhaps
the picture story of the day don't know
why you picked this one out santa paused
the headline
my director is cuddly gushing over this
picture i can tell you
a really good news story off the back of
all the covered news and the idea that
children how are they going to develop
in the future on the back of the sort of
story that ramona was just talking about
here's some good news here's something
we can all smile about and these are
shetland sheepdogs i think most of them
about six of the seven you can see there
and this is kaylee garrick she's a 31
year old paramedic up in scotland and
she dresses up her dogs and sells the
images for charity but also shows the
pictures to some of her patients in the
ambulance to distract them from the pain
and also puts them up in hospital as
well now i've got two dogs through my
girlfriend i was not a dog person at all
before i met my girlfriend now i
absolutely love them in fact last night
i just tweeted a couple of images of our
working cocker spaniels i'm not sure i'm
going to be dressing them up in that in
the christmas hat i've got just over my
shoulder but i think this sort of story
we all need we all need to do a bit of
smiling ahead of christmas
just to to inform our viewers the
shetland sheepdogs are named fenton
thiago thorin gimli murphy jarrah she
also has an alaskan clichy called ghost
and an eighth which can sometimes be
seen another shetland sheepdog fiona
absolutely lovely